comment est ce qu'on arrive à organiser
un covoiturage avec la collectivité pour
emmener les personnes les plus en
difficulté ils sont venus de toute la
bourgogne parler de leur quotidien et de
leur difficulté à se déplacer dans la
région
chacun d'entre eux touchera 70 euros
d'indemnités pour cette journée
citoyenne
mais l'argent n'est pas leur motivation
je serais venu sans être défrayés je
voulais j'ai pas peur de le dire
j'aurais pu très bien venir sans être
défrayés
je pense que le sujet est important
quand on vient de sens justement une
kilomètres ça fait et voilà ça présente
un coût en essence non négligeable ça
peut peut-être inciter des gens à venir
notamment des gens qui au niveau
financier va fallait se déplacer pour
venir ici ça peut les aider à pouvoir
participer à l'origine de cette journée
citoyenne la région bourgogne franche
comté
elles tiennent à indemniser les 50
participants et à leur rembourser les
frais de déplacement la moitié est
volontaire
l'autre tiré au sort dans la salle
quelques élus venus répondre aux
questions ils soutiennent l'initiative
prise par la région six pour avoir un
panel représentatif
il faut passer par ce type d'initiative
propositions pour moi la réponse est oui
sinon ça sera les personnes qui auront
les moyens qu'on retrouvera dans les
assemblées où les personnes les plus
proches
donc ils ne seront pas représentative ça
c'est certain la région de son côté
rappelle que cette pratique est ancienne
et qu'elle n'a jamais posé problème mais
aussi que cette journée citoyenne était
prévu avant même le mouvement des gilet
jaune
d'autres journées sont déjà programmés
cette année
l'église une voiture vous apprendre de
l'autopartage et je m'excuserai